I I think he doesn't deserve certain  team but I don't think legally they can  do it unless I think it has to do with  money I don't know what the NBA's  mandate is I don't know what their their  structure is but I mean if they have the  ability to force an owner out I think  that that's what they should do now but  what do you feel about sterling heard  Magic Johnson is interested with the  guggenheim group of taking over the  Clippers and I think that would be a  great idea i'll ask Billy Billy they one  of cares to buy the Clippers our  associations we ever seen Billy Crystal  to take over the Clippers well maybe he  could be their point guard